[Música]
aquí comienza a ella soy de france 24 el
juicio de difamación / amber heard y
johnny depp llegó a su fin luego de seis
intensas semanas las partes pudieron
exponer sus testimonios en el condado de
fairfax en virginia y tras testimonios y
opiniones expertas el jurado determinó
que ambos eran culpables de difamación
aunque la suma de dinero que la actriz
es deberá pagar al actor por daños y
perjuicios es más alta que la que debe
tendrá que desembolsar para comenzar
veamos el resumen de ariana villacorta
un triunfo de la verdad y de la justicia
así es como los abogados de johnny depp
calificaron la decisión de un jurado de
virginia que determinó que la actriz
amber heard y famoso ex exposo al
acusarlo de violencia doméstica dando
así fin a un mediático juicio que duró
seis semanas
ahora que el jurado ha llegado a su
veredicto concluyente es hora de pasar
página y mirar al futuro
pero antes de que este capítulo pase al
olvido el jurado ordenó también a johnny
depp desembolsar dos millones de dólares
a la actriz por daños y perjuicios
mientras que heart tendrá que pagarle al
protagonista de piratas del caribe más
de 10 millones de dólares es un
retroceso retrocede a una época en la
que una mujer que hablaba y denunciaba
podría ser avergonzada y humillada
públicamente hace retroceder la idea de
que la violencia contra las mujeres debe
ser tomada en serio
de demandó ayer por 50 millones de
dólares y argumentó que lo difamó cuando
se llamó a sí misma una figura pública
que representa el abuso doméstico en un
artículo de opinión publicado en the
washington post en el que no nombraba a
depp pero que el actor asegura le trajo
graves consecuencias la actriz reaccionó
poniendo una contrademanda a su exmarido
por un valor de 100 millones de dólares
en el juicio que fue televisado y
seguido por millones de personas
alrededor del mundo tanto de como hertz
revelaron detalles íntimos de su vida en
pareja y ambos detallaron situaciones de
abuso durante su relación y la
conversación sobre el tema es con
carolina duer ella es doctora en
ciencias sociales de la uba magíster en
comunicación y cultura y licenciada en
ciencias de la comunicación carolina
bienvenida a ellos hoy el jurado le dio
la razón a hertz en al menos uno de los
cargos y estableció que depp también
cometió difamación contra ella porque la
sentencia final favoreció al actor
a ver creo que la sentencia final
favoreció al actor porque el juicio
tenía como objetivo probar o no que los
dichos de amber heard en su artículo the
washington post
eran difamatorios o no respecto de
johnny depp si bien ella no lo nombra a
él directamente se presenta como
representante de las víctimas de
violencia doméstica entonces lo que él
lo que eso a él le permite es presentar
una demanda que también habilita este
juicio este juicio que duró seis semanas
y cuyo objetivo y me parece esto muy
importante recalcar es que el veredicto
no tenía que ver con estar a favor de
uno o en contra de otro oa favor de
alguno sino responder una serie de
preguntas puntuales que tenían que estar
acompañados por evidencias provenientes
del juicio en relación con el artículo
por ejemplo una pregunta era el artículo
se refirió directamente a johnny depp
parte de la defensa amberger dijo que no
durante todo el tiempo y en su última
declaración testimonial de ella en el
juicio dijo que lo había escrito contra
él entonces la cantidad de pruebas
respuestas que tenía que dar el jurado
favorecieron porque la defensa de amber
no logró representar de manera
articulada las pruebas que permitieran
entender que ese artículo no era contra
johnny depp más algo ella termina
explicitando el anteúltimo día del
juicio que lo escribió contra él por la
desigualdad de poder que ambos
detentaban en hollywood entonces creo
que la sentencia de favoreció en un
juicio por difamación no es un juicio
por violencia doméstica pero él sí pudo
probar junto con sus abogados que ella
había sido violenta de manera directa
con él esto supone que él no fue
violento nunca con ella para nada esto
no es lo que dijo el veredicto un juicio
en el reino unido sobre violencia
doméstica en la que en el que ella ganó
con distinto tipo de evidencia
pero en este caso puntual la prueba de
difamación se concreta por la falta de
sustento de todo el testimonio de heart
y de sus especialistas
pero cuando estábamos fuera del aire
preparando este programa usted me decía
que de todas maneras está muy
sorprendida por este por esta decisión
que tomó el jurado al final tiene que
ver la decisión también con el hecho de
que hubo toda una campaña en redes
sociales que de una de las partes pues
avergonzaron a gente de su actitud su
comportamiento sus gestos faciales
durante el juicio y además más allá de
eso que excusado en el actor y lo ponían
como una víctima de violencia por parte
de su exmujer
creo que el gran hallazgo que tuvo este
juicio a nivel
procedimental fue que el audio que nos
escuchamos fue cuando ella le dice a él
por qué no decís johnny depp soy víctima
de violencia doméstica a ver qué juez y
qué jurado te da la razón creo que una
de las de las virtudes de la defensa de
de componer este audio como la gran
síntesis y ella tiene que reconocer que
efectivamente la había pegado y ella en
el audio ese dice bueno tampoco te pegó
tan fuerte entonces ellos se pusieron en
la característica de ella como violenta
por un lado para otro lado es cierto que
el juicio fue creyendo que quiero decir
con esto que quienes vimos el juicio
desde el día lunes cuando éramos 20 30
mil personas en el canal oficial de
lohan crime lo que sabemos es que la los
perfiles de los personajes porque
estamos pensando como un evento
mediático también las personas fueron
cambiando la comunicación del cuerpo de
ambas ideas los protagonistas se
modificó totalmente el primer testimonio
de johnny depp era prácticamente de una
persona abatida y lo que encontramos
ahora lo encontramos en las últimas dos
semanas es una persona que estaba
convencida y más sólido incluso en su
postura física yo creo que el fallo me
sorprende porque pensé como él o el
juicio penal pensé que iban a encontrar
puntos intermedios de responsabilidad y
corresponsabilidad porque lo que quiero
es probado a lo largo de las seis
semanas de juicio con los múltiples
testigos y múltiples testimonios es que
la relación en una relación enferma de
ambas partes lo que ocurre es que bueno
efectivamente la gran preocupación y
esto lo estuve trabajando esta semana
con un equipo de especialistas tienen
que ver con cuál es el precedente que
sienta este respecto de denuncias de
mujeres por violencia doméstica de
desigualdades y de qué manera este caso
puede ser utilizado de mala manera como
un caso testigo respecto de las
denuncias por parte de mujeres de
violencia doméstica entonces creo que
hay que incorporar una definición amplia
de violencia doméstica que incluye la
violencia simbólica y la violencia y la
violencia física y también la violencia
institucional adversaria dijo que va a
apelar este fallo así que creo que queda
todavía la historia por contar y si
estoy entendiendo bien pues es muy
importante hacer la aclaración en que
una cosa es un juicio por de información
y otra cosa es un juicio por violencia
doméstica como le llaman en términos de
eeuu o por violencia machista sin
embargo para seguir hablando de en qué
quedan las denuncias de las mujeres pues
aquí queda muy bien entredicho el
movimiento me tú qué tanta mella ha
hecho principalmente en eeuu como país
qué va a pasar con las mujeres que no
tenemos esa visibilidad que no tenemos
esos recursos para interponer una
demanda y para defendernos o para
continuar nuestra vida pues una vez que
termine este episodio bochornoso que
pasa con nosotras porque el hecho de que
deba haya ganado un juicio por
difamación no implica que no hubo abuso
exacto no implica que tengo abuso y el
gran problema y el gran desafío que
tenemos como comunicadores y
comunicadoras es
transmitir que esto no es un caso
testigo y que está en un juicio por
difamación no era un juicio por
violencia doméstica lo que ocurre es que
como lo que se alegó como parte de la
información era la violencia doméstica y
no se pudo aprobar de manera fehaciente
tal como el procedimiento judicial lo
establece me dieron la razón a él porque
la prueba lo favorecía esta no significa
no significa que no haya habido
situaciones de violencia de él hacia
ella durante toda su matrimonio que de
hecho lo que vemos es que el momento que
se empiezan a grabar ya tomar registros
de la vida cotidiana conjunta ya nos
damos cuenta que el nivel de agresividad
y de iu de acusaciones cruzadas
realmente insostenible cuando ella
cuenta determinadas anécdotas y él
cuenta lo que lo que aparece
lamentablemente y se activa es cierto
nivel de morbo respecto de la vida
privada de dos celebridades y es cuando
se despido durante seis semanas ese
espacio absolutamente íntimo en un
espacio público que como decía solamente
en el canal oficial del juicio pasó de
20 mil
a casi tres millones y medio el día del
veredicto claro y por eso siento un
presente tan importante mi última
pregunta porque ya nos quedamos sin
tiempo carolina y ese citando un
artículo de opinión del 'new york times'
escrito por la periodista michele
goldberg entonces ella cita un episodio
que fue el que le dio la razón a ejercen
un cargo de difamación en el que ella
está hablando con un amigo porque johnny
depp le estaba haciendo reclamos sobre
este amigo y él dice que escucha por
teléfono como deb la ataca violentamente
y luego la defensa de brizé es que todo
método fue un complot no para acusarlo a
él y la el jurado encuentra que esto es
falso que esto es difamación porque no
se trató de un complot es decir está un
poco admitiendo que si hubo maltrato que
si hubo abuso y si si hubo abuso pues
para esta columnista pues el tema de
difamación tambalea un poco mientras que
por el otro lado están las pruebas que
ya vienen saliendo desde el juicio del
reino unido- de textos en los que de
johnny depp dice abiertamente que
quisiera matarla y luego violar su
cadáver textos en los que hablan vídeos
en los que le habla violentamente pelea
en ella intenta calmarlo en el que le
levanta un cuchillo contra ella entonces
no queda un poco en entredicho aun así
el juicio por difamación no es un poco
sorprendente porque si ella lo difamó
pues todas estas pruebas no estarían ahí
para todos a la vista
sí yo creo que acá lo que lo que tenemos
que evaluar es el procedimiento judicial
y quienes seguimos desde el día 1 el
procedimiento judicial lo que vemos es
que todo esto que hemos comentadas y que
acuerdo no estuvo reflejado ni
representado por pruebas materiales en
el juicio y lamentablemente la gran
preocupación que queda ahora para las
mujeres y para el movimiento feminista
tiene que ver con cómo hacer para
construir
un espacio en el que las mujeres
oxidamos confiando en hacer denuncias y
no consideramos que este es un caso
testigo porque efectivamente las
particularidades realmente violentas de
ambos en el en la relación no se vieron
representadas por lo menos en este
juicio en este juicio uno podría pensar
bueno todo lo claro con una estrategia
judicial adecuada o tuvo que ver con que
una parte tenía pruebas y la otra la
tenía las suficientes pero como no
tenemos información para responder
la idea de que un texto y la otra debe
dar un cuchillo y entonces el nivel de
violencia cotidiana que había hace que
me parece que el juicio de violencia no
está en cuestión la pregunta es si una
información el jurado dijo que sí y lo
que nosotros encontramos como
espectadores de este espectáculo que fue
un juicio tiene que ver con la
imposibilidad que tuvo ella de mostrar
de manera sistemática y organizada
y organizada que era una víctima de
violencia de de vivencia doméstica está
bien eso significa que no sea una
víctima de violencia doméstica pues no
lo que ocurre es que lo que estamos
analizando es un juicio no es una
opinión individual sobre lo que ocurrió
mira carolina ya nos quedamos sin tiempo
pero gracias a ustedes por sus opiniones
y pues para eso estamos aquí para hacer
la evaluación y sobre todo para animar a
las mujeres a que no permitan que haya
violencia en sus hogares ni en ningún
ámbito de la vida gracias a ustedes a
nuestros televidentes por estar con
nosotros y nos vemos próximamente en
ellas hoy
[Música]